thion à cette annonce ce matin cette
demande de huis clos de vincent écrase
est ce que pour vous et dans une fois
que céder à cette demande de huis clos
de cet autre homme de la sphère benalla
d'abord je ne suis pas d'accord pour lui
clos et je ne comprends pas pourquoi il
demande lui clos franchement
vous savez lemagit cela peut demander le
pv de l'audition 1
alors ça c'est le protège en rien c'est
encore probablement bien une pression de
l'elysée et j'espère que l'autre est
notre commission ne va pas exploser à la
suite
dandy quelconque différend effectivement
vous pensez que tout le monde n'est pas
forcément d'accord là dessus un certain
sont plutôt favorables au big lots au
sein du sénat ce n'est pas du tout c'est
ça non moi c'est pas mon cas j'en ai on
est là on doit on doit auditionner
monsieur kraz on a auditionné d'autres
le on a auditionné le commissaire de
kiki était à la direction se creuse à
huy lê maxence clausa qui était à la
direction ne soit de l'ordre public et
de la circulation
donc je ne vois pas pourquoi et lui
aussi est poursuivi bon alors si vous
l'accordé on peut craindre que ça fasse
boule de neige avec également l'audition
d'alexandre benalla ne sais pas merci
beaucoup esther benbassa d'avoir répondu
à m